If you've applied for a telephone down card,
phone bill is very comfortable Plean such as six thousand beginning,
telomeres get five hundred minutes daily S.
M. S.
gave a dormitory home three hundred minutes of internet digs and then gave you
a bought-for-you-to-like-mindedness,
you've also got to give yourself a bought-in-of-your-return-your-you-your-your
-your-your-your-your-you-you-you-your-your-your-you-you-your-your-your-your-
your-your-your-your-your-your-your-your-your-your-your-your-your-your-your-your
-you-you-your-your-your-your-your-your-your
-you-you-you-you-you-you-your-bill-you-
Um.
Also if it's eight thousand plankton
He is this tony telenor
We give each other a thousand minutes every day on the phone,
the SS said
If a day's dormitory
I gotta get three hundred everyday,
I gotta get a vowel from the internet kick
Phone bill for custom reuse
which i added
The eight thousand I added to buy plan,
also as a phone bill
Give it back to me
If it's ten thousand planets,
don't talk on the phone to each other for a thousand minutes every day
The other SS said three hundred daily dormitories.
The internet is definitely going to give Poe Point Figs.
I also returned ten thousand phone bills for custom recycling,
okay?
I don't want to get so many phone minutes If I want to spend plankton getting
so much data If there are still such plankas,
he must add ten-and-a-half hundred and buy plankton We give each other a
thousand minutes of telephone calls everyday
Fifty minutes internet gave me six gigs
And in return for the recycling,
M.
B returns two and a half hundred thousand times this year to buy data packages
exclusively If he uses them as data,
every Internet this directly enables,
twenty-five period,
total,
thirty-one contemporary
If it's twenty thousand and a hundred plankton
He's gonna get a thousand minutes on the phone to each other everyday
The other call minute was a hundred.
The internet gig was eight.
I give back four hundred thousand feet.
This return of four hundred thousand feet is for local exclusivity.
If internet region is open,
you can use forty gigs
In total,
we could use a total of forty-eight gigs in twenty thousand planes.
If it's twenty thousand and a half
He telephoned each other minutes ago
Three thousand everyday
Other call minutes could be a hundred and fifty Internet data
I got eleven gigs
As a bonus bill,
you get even eight hundred thousand dances This eight hundred thousand equals
eighty-one gigs if you use data Internet data exclusively,
the total is twenty thousand,
you can use ninety-two gigs
Too precious I can apply for these little baptisms with the disembarkation
card I currently use as I apply for a Napoleon shake just give me a phone
number I will laugh two thousand times and then I can apply